before the break we met rachel grimm
who wrote into the show seeking advice
on how to repair her relationship with
her mother
we are joined by her mother tana becker
tana i'm really interested and excited
to hear
what your experience was what you are
going through
well first of all i love both my kids so
i love them very much so i didn't
never uh set out to hurt them or you
know anything like that but
um
it was just a really rough time my son i
guess it was 2007 he was diagnosed with
diabetes and up until that point i was
pretty much able to control everything
that happened to them
and i liked that you know because i
could keep them safe
and
that happened and then um
then in 2008 we had a
family business and
the recession kind of started
tearing away at that
and i was felt like i was losing control
and then
my husband coming and telling me that we
were gonna lose our home
so
i was like i i just had it in my head
that i need a break so i just was like
i've i've had enough you know i need to
they're old enough and
they'll be fine with their dad because
he's a good person so i packed my stuff
and
i moved out
and your daughter is 18 yes but your son
is 15 yes when you leave
did you tell them you were leaving
they knew that i was leaving because
they saw everything being packed up
because i took time to pack things
because
i felt guilty but i needed it
so when i was
getting things together and packing
things up i was only taking what i
absolutely needed because i didn't want
to
um
make it worse than what it was going to
be you know
this i think is something that
is very important for me to ask
and for you to hear
um how did you feel
when tana left
i mean
it was obviously
very hard and
heartbreaking i mean my mom had always
instilled in me such a
level of confidence to be myself and to
live the life i dream
and
i felt like she was one of my biggest
cheerleaders and for her to leave in
that time that was where i was finally
going after that thing you know going to
college and pursuing this dream that we
had like talked about so much
um
for her to be gone in that time was
obviously
hurtful and
caused me to have a lot of
resent for
some time um
there was a really emotional moment
where you showed up at the airport can
you guys talk to each other about that
absolutely well she was asking me
earlier about
when we would have started like really
talking and trying to
work on a relationship and
i really look back to when i was in
london studying abroad as that time
just talked about you know what life was
like
what life was like
for you back home and what life was like
for me
in england
and um you know i really treasured those
emails and those moments and so when you
were there when i got off the plane and
even though you know you and my dad
weren't together anymore but you were
both there to pick me up
sorry
um
to me it was like a sign of moving
forward right of of what it had the
potential to be yep
i mean tana what are your expectations
moving forward and also what
are you able to manage so that rachel
can hear this and not expect highs where
you might not be able to deliver
what is your
vision moving forward i would just
like to have total forgiveness yeah
and
just
for us to be able to build
a relationship from here
and just and try to get
get something back
that we have i mean i know it's not ever
going to be the same
but at the same time
you're much you're older now too and it
will be different
but the forgiveness is
is what i'm looking for
i'm just going to say something too i
don't know about any of you but
daughters to mothers like
i think we have a predisposed
expectation where we don't want you to
be selfish you know and i i i will tell
you i am i still am i'm a very selfish
person okay i'm glad you said that
because i think very need to hear that
and it's not what you want to hear but
i'm glad that is out i am a very selfish
person when it comes to myself i like
what i like when i like it and i'm just
i it's just me it's the way i am but
i'm learning
in the past few years i'm really
learning to work on that that i to put
others first
it's hard it is hard thank you thank you
thank you
thank you
really honestly
my mom was selfish too yeah
and it screwed me up yeah but you know
what
i
carried that with me yeah and i acted as
a place from a wounded child yes who
also felt like they had to be an adult
too quickly
and i didn't understand the parent-child
dynamic this is a big thing in therapy
there's a reason they call it a
parent-child dynamic
and when that skew is off it is
confusing
and as selfish as my mom was
um i have to give her a lot of room too
because
i was not easy
our life was uh set up for a crash and
burn disaster
um i was a child actor i was going out i
was completely out of control she
actually had to put me in an institution
and she did not know how to control me
anymore things were out of control i got
legally emancipated from her at 14.
these were very painful things for both
of us to go through
and i know that she has her side of the
story and she's not here to tell her
perspective but i know that she had a
man who left before i was born
she had
a past with her family
her choices came from things that were
real for her
and as a woman i could finally see and
understand that yeah and we've made
peace
and we now text and talk and i can reach
out to her and i
know this is morbid but i'm so relieved
that she's still here on this planet
so that i have the chance
to do this with her
and another thing i want to say is as
you're growing together in this new
chapter
you guys have spent a lot of time apart
so if feelings start to flare and rise
up go to your corners give each other
some space
you know regulate you guys have survived
a lot of time apart you don't need to be
this right now yeah right and
you can move forward
allowing that time and space yes um
it has been such a privilege to be a
part of this conversation
and if you would like to continue it um
after the show we actually
um have someone that we can set you up
with awesome um who's incredible and an
actual trained professional who i am not
i am just but you did amazing yes this
is amazing so healing
i'm so glad yeah
she needs you
thank you thank you thank you for doing
this with us absolutely thank you thank
you thank you to rachel graham and
connor becker for sharing your story and
being so vulnerable with me i am with
you please let's keep in touch let's
check in and keep this going
[Music]